welcome everybody to this I mean special
very special interview for me
interviewing two of the stars from this
new bong joon-ho film called parasite
that is in my opinion one of the best
films of the year and should be
nominated for Best Picture
not just Best Foreign Language Picture
Best Picture the two people who are with
me today our stars of the film song
kang-ho and park sodam welcome to
Collider how are you iliza meet you
pleasure to meet you both
as well I want to start and ask a song
first I want to ask you you've worked
with director bong now four-on-four
films memories of murder the host
snowpiercer and now parasite how has he
changed as a director from when you work
with him in memories of murder to now
with parasite the first thing the change
his changes that he gained a lot of
weight I wanna ask you what was your
process in creating the character of Kim
Koo Jun is this someone you knew or
someone you've you've gotten to know or
or grew up with did you base that on her
did you create something completely
original from your own studying as an
actor from the first time that I read
the scenario I realized how all the
lines felt very natural to me and
everything was written as if it was my
line that I wrote to a point where I
thought if I wonder if dr. Bernardi
noumea has been studying Who I am as a
person I didn't feel like I'd to
memorize every single line because
everything just made sentence came out
very naturally or never seen and I
couldn't wait to start acting with
everyone I would say that he's young and
I are very quite similar person oh so
you are sweet one minute and then
ruthless the next is that correct and
you kind of person anyone that you would
meet isn't just one-dimensional and they
have multifaceted personality not
because they are people
and I believe there are multiple
different situations and seeing where I
was able to bring myself but also play
and show different side of key junk that
people love so I think that's just how
pertinent and how human is so the shoot
was 76 days what are some of the
memorable moments you had on set
shooting this film that makes it
different from some of the other films
you've shot with bong joon-ho
could the rich family house was a set as
well as the poor family house so in
previous films with I've seen other
interviews with you you were very
honored to work with and bong joon-ho
was there anything that surprised you
about working with them as an actor and
director I truly consider myself lucky
throughout the entire process of
shooting because I was one of the very
first people to witness amazing acting
that some Ganga does and not everyone
has to get that experience so I was
really thankful I was I felt lucky and
blessed and I do feel like I learned a
lot as a person but also as an actor
yeah I asked you what excited you about
the themes or the symbolism in the movie
because obviously we have class warfare
rich versus poor but also so much more
happening beneath the surface on both
sides did you in find that so enriching
to read when you were encountering the
script personally I think this piece is
very ambitious one for a director bong
joon-ho on the surface this is a
conflict between the rich and the poor
in a larger picture this accommodates
the entire human race the history of it
that we fight
reconcile war so we're still struggling
I think the whole movie is was trying to
encompass the entire oh I like that
answer it's a very good answer
parts of them you're a young actress yes
the themes the symbolism in the move me
in the movie speak to a larger picture
as a song was referencing here more
Universal historical picture what was it
like for you to read the script and see
all the twists and turns within it but
also what it has to say about us as
human beings
I'm sure that you can relate that as a
human being when we even in the within a
day or we within the hour we don't just
live with one emotion there's always a
constant change and we don't just have
one day where we're constantly happy
from beginning to an end and also in a
similar way if we were to if I were to
walk out that door no one can predict
what's going to happen the next five
minute and I think that the
unforeseeable feature the volatility of
how the life is seems like is what
director bond was able to capture an
illustrator within the phone and that
allowed that's where the richness of the
film came from I believe and because of
that every scene felt more like just a
regular life where I could just submerge
and assimilate into rather than feel
like an acting into one specific no I
like that that's great so a song do you
have any rituals before you get onto a
set and perform a scene or a more
emotional scene do you have anything
that you go through for yourself that
you and bong joon-ho kind of work out
ahead of time boat I need other actors
seem to have something like called jinkx
well think of me actually no I don't
think I have any specific ritual that I
go through before are there shades of
your own father in the character you
play in the movie are there do you do
you reference from your own experience
with your own father you know because
he's he trying to raise this family in
the situation that they're in in certain
parts in general our
fathers they always try very hard to
raise their family to to provide for
their family but they struggle and then
there are their dreams in their their
efforts are not only ways paid back so
yeah I I want to go back to you Park I'm
doing some research on you it says I
don't know if it's true that you saw
Greece and this made you want to become
an actress but you've done you know you
tried in numerous places and had to
figure out how to get yourself in to be
seen for things and now you've got a
career how strong is your drive to be
successful you would assume every
project I work in I run into a lot of
different people and not just actors and
actresses but all the staff that worked
in the entire big production of the
films like such as parasite and for me I
tend to feed off positive energy and
that's what kind of keeps me going in
order to move forward every day by day
scene by scene because of that I always
am very thankful for to the actors and
actresses and the staff that's involved
in any high project I work with to be
honest before I start I worked on
parasite because I was still in the
beginning stage of my career that I
wasn't able to see in a big picture of
how a set is run what it goes into and
how much work actually that goes into it
for me it was more about just making
sure I can do my job at an accurate and
just get that done well so that I don't
have any I'm not causing any more
trouble to other people but this time
around for some reason I was able to see
how much work that goes into it and how
many people are running around to make
before I miss standing in front of a
camera and how much work and effort that
time has been put into that so I'm
always thankful to the people that
allowed me to be able to be the best
version of myself and also I'm very I
feel very lucky and then also because of
that I feel like that's my motivation to
do even better and to become even more
successful is because of everything that
they've have done for me and the only
the best way for me to give back is by
being better at what I do as an actor
that sounds like a director do you have
a favorite song from Greece I think I'm
a bit nervous I can't think of the exact
title where
good for the guys and the girls meet and
then they sing that summer love it yeah
I go back to your song why do you think
parasite has struck a nerve with so many
people it describes the Korean families
however it's not the situation is not
just relevant in Korea it's very common
all around the world
says it's like it feels like it's my
story it's my neighbor's story 20 any
people I think that's why it has this
wide of healing did you realize you were
making something great something
different then maybe you've done before
song you've spoken in previous
interviews how this feels like a more
focused bong joon-ho more precise bong
joon-ho do you did you realize that as
you were making the film yes of course I
cannot reveal the details of course
because there are people who haven't
seen the movie but it's very dramatic
and just like you know when we
experience all kinds of emotions while
we alive right we live like a choice so
this movie cannot you can really say
this is a genre film it's more like a
combination of all different genres like
they tumble around insist you know every
kind of genres and it's mixed in this
film so it's kind of very unique did you
realize that as well that this is
something completely new that you maybe
haven't done before
I believe that my first emotion was and
I was in awe when I was reading through
this script and that was because I
noticed that because you see is built
around the two very basic core structure
of a family of a mother father father
daughter and a son and there's two
different family Kim's and parts but
just with those two small structure
family it's somehow portrayed and
illustrated the life that we live in and
decided that we're with living in
I felt like it was a good epitome and
illustration of the curt's aside that
we're here in this time and felt also
when I was acting that it wouldn't be
something does limited to a Korean
culture and Korean audience but more a
global and more wider understanding from
audiences will be received because of
that and and it's happening yes agreed
yeah agreed
how did you create the family within the
four of you did you go out and have
dinner did you go and did you speak to
the other actors who were playing the
rich family at all or did you keep a
distance from each other until the
shooting on the set the entire shooting
process of 76 days I feel like we all
the actors were always constantly
together
it wasn't about dividing into Kim's and
parts and it wasn't but it felt more
like on the holiday all the big other
extended family gathered in law's that's
how it felt and it wasn't and it just
didn't it was natural and didn't have to
try anything to force it but because
we're constantly together eating
together drinking together and
disbanding time together that it didn't
feel like we had to force to do anything
to build our bond but it naturally
happen by spending time together at the
group mmm were you the leader of the
whole group whatever song went everyone
else went better gotcha
it seems like Park would know everywhere
to go it seems like from I looked at
your Instagram you're very busy
constantly doing stuff I'm sure you knew
where to take them and where to go
directly question but it still feels
very unreal to the fact that I'm here in
the studio in LA in the States having
this interview and even when I was in
New York last weekend now in LA
every day when I come back from when I
come back to my hotel room I still
didn't feel like I just had a day so I
will try to post as much as I can on
Instagram to suit visit different spec
places but also just look through all
the photos that people have taken of us
during our interview which every picture
that I scroll through made it more real
to me when I reviewed it at the end of
the night and also I was also very
curious to see how the audience in the
States are receiving this film and what
they're saying about it so I see I do
spend a lot of time on social media just
to understand and have to connect with
audiences
you should pinch it's real it's real I
want to ask you a question you've worked
with bone Juho nails as I said with four
films you very obviously you have a
friendship with him and and interactions
with him has how much did the script
change from when you first read it to
what we see on the screen now and did
you offer any suggestions or changes for
the overall script that came about he
doesn't change from the script stage to
actual shooting like there's not little
change because he's very so you didn't
no changes he discussed two very
important scenes with me hmm
once climax I cannot tell you what it is
and then there's the one part that right
before before to reach to get to the
climax so here we discussed about you
know what emotions what was your biggest
challenge here there was you you there's
a lot of physical stuff you go through I
don't want to give away too much and I
really do hope that the audience come
see the foam and then we can talk about
it later but there is a scene where some
of the characters are drenched in rain
yeah and that we have to run through the
streets and there was a lot of water and
it was and by a lot we mean a lot and it
was because I saw any of the wet scene
go it does get very cold and it's very
physical scene to go through and it's
even harder when they're running
you're soaked in water and heavier but
it was it looks great and I hope people
would see it but it was very hard to
shoot yeah I can only imagine when the
film wrapped did you each get a rock or
no I want to ask mark one last question
here what what do you take from this
move how has the movie the experience
here changed you not only as an actress
but as as a person as a human being
don't move man and I'm not sure how to
phrase it but it was more about the
biggest difference from before and now
is the responsibility that I've derived
from overly abundant affection and
interest and love from everyone that has
not seen me in the film as an actor I do
feel like it's the burden is heavier now
because something that I started just
create something I started could
actually enjoyed and now I feel like I
have this responsibility to always do
better to return the love and affection
that audience has been supporting and
sending my way but at the same time I do
believe that this film also has given me
an amazing network of people that I've
met amazing actors and staff and the
people in the industry and also
audiences that those part the energy I
get from them is something that I feed
off from them will be enough for me to
go forward and to meet the
responsibilities that I feel now do
either of you want to be in a Marvel
superhero movie or DC superhero movie
there are already plenty of Korean young
Korean actors were already acting in
these superhero movies so I think I will
defer when I saw the movie I thought
immediately you should be doing these
movies you'd be great actually she she's
great in action she's ugly Oh
action movie actor to be honest in the
beginning it the idea of working in
Hollywood idea of being part of Marvel
or DC Comics film just felt very distant
and very
unreachable so to speak for the lack of
a better word but to be fully honest at
the moment after since I had a right to
the state that have been met amazing
people although audiences and
understanding the feedback in how
amazing the film has been so far I will
be lying if I say I didn't have a
thought about it and she's slightly
building up but as you can see I have a
lot of English to study one last
question we got to wrap up what do you
want people to take from parricide after
they see it what do you hope the film
accomplishes get well the audience will
certainly get cinematic fun and then
they will can also think about the
society self but I believe everybody
will have a different feelings in the
end but hopefully what I really like is
that anyone you know these people will
still the audience will still think
about the movie even after they go we
like to say that the less you know about
the movie and watch it it's better and
more you take away from it so we really
hope that audiences don't look up
anything so hopefully I don't get spoke
any spoilers and I prefer preferably
come to the theater a more vulnerable
state so that you can truly enjoy what
you see and what you feel and afterward
this is one of those movie where you
have a lot to talk up to other people
about and we really hope that you are
able to have their discussion and bigger
conversations after have seen the movie
so don't look up anything and please I'm
gonna need to learn Korean it's it's out
limited release now but it's gonna be
rolling out more and more theaters go
see this thing I'm telling you this
thing is the best picture and don't go
see it once go see it multiple times
you're gonna get so much out of this
movie from bong joon-ho alright this is
John Roca for Collider thank you so much
for watching this interview we'll talk
to you soon